i turn away from
violence or
films usually that have violence or tv
or anything that has that sort of
um
element to it except in certain
cases where um
where the violence is beautiful
yeah yeah
or um
did you see the movie true romance
uh yes that's my second favorite movie
okay that's probably my favorite movie
yeah oh well interesting that's my
second favorite movie um that's that's a
more uh simple kind of love but also
with the violence that is beautiful yeah
as you could say yeah and my um
my favorite scene is the one with
patricia arquette and james gandolfini
oh yeah was she there's a shotgun
involved yeah yeah
and then it actually makes me cry every
time i see it
for some reason
so for people who haven't seen the film
i think i think he's actually he thinks
he's hitting her
or
uh like there's blood and violence and
so on because he's resisting being
murdered
yeah there's a lot of violence and then
you know he throws her into the glass
um the shower yeah
thing and she's all cut up and beat up
and only and she laughs
yeah there's just so much passion in it
you know she's she knows she's gonna or
in that moment she
knows or thinks she knows that she's
gonna die anyway yeah because she she
knows he's gonna kill her yeah so she
kind of gives it her
gives it all she has and um
but she also just says guts she's not
afraid
yeah well and also she's um
you know she loves clarence
yeah the love comes through through that
violence yeah yeah just like
clarence her fella
in that film
uh has the same kind of thing when he
visits well it was gary oldman again it
was gary oldman again that's right the
pimp looking very drexel
yeah yeah and he's also fearless in that
interaction saying she's not mine
it's interesting that movie is so
romantic
and that a happy ending spoiler alert in
a way that's what i like about it too
because i i feel like some movies should
come with
i don't want to watch a movie if it's
going to be devastating usually unless
it's worthwhile in some other way but
i'm kind of sensitive and i don't want
um i don't like movies that have a
terrible ending you know i mean
there's a book i read because it got so
many good reviews and the very last
scene the woman steps in front of a
train and it was like
um so i'm partial to movies with happy
endings leon ends
with loss
beyond the movie right but it's still
inspiring a love persists in some kind
of form yeah persists and the plant and
the plant
um okay sure sure
uh drew romance does have one of the i
mean
it's probably unhealthy and the only
scene is just amazing you're so cool was
she
is that one where she just kind of
looks at clarence and her son and child
or whatever and
she's saying you're so cool you're so
cool
yeah
that's that's love
i just felt moving so much in it because
it's
you know it's funny and there's so many
so many good actors in that film and
brad pitt uh plays in that
film a pivotal role of pothead on couch
yeah they're just they're all so good
and funny and michael rappaport yeah and
um and even val kilmer people don't
realize he's in the movie because he
doesn't look like himself
um wait what what did falcon val
kilmer's in the very end it's
um you know when he's there's like the
elvis sitting there
talking to him in the end yeah that's
val kilmer
yeah you don't notice it unless you
yeah somehow either are very perceptive
or noticed in the credits yeah and uh
quentin tarantino wrote the film i think
yes which is interesting
uh directed by tony scott and the music
is uh beautiful too and christopher
walken and um
um
dennis
hopper dennis hopper dennis hopper plays
clarence's
uh dad and they have this
very racist sounding scene but
the big
uh
important aspect of that scene is it's a
father
willing to die to protect the sun i mean
it's so much so much beautiful violence
there is
there is i love that phil so much uh and
she's a prostitute or not really
part-time short time no it was her first
time first time yeah
okay and he saved her
and uh
hmm
my third favorite film has no violence
whatsoever what's your third um a room
with a view
i feel like you'd like it
it's um
um
i forget the author it's a book and i i
read the book much later um but it's
um helena bonham carter
and um
uh daniel day-lewis
is in it and julian sands
daniel day lewis is a fascinating
character
he's amazing in this film because he
plays
he's very funny he sort of plays a he's
a comical character which is unlike
most of what he does i think i don't
watch a ton of movies so
um but
yeah he played his his role is funny
you